thank you very much ever before I begin
I'd like to offer my condolences and
best wishes to the people all across our
great south who have endured deadly
tornadoes and other severe weather in
Texas Louisiana Mississippi Alabama
Florida Georgia Tennessee in South
Carolina my administration will do
everything possible to help those
communities get back on their feet we're
speaking with the governor's and
Representatives FEMA is already on its
way and they got there as soon as we
heard the word I said get out there so
FEMA is there and you know the great job
that FEMA does it's really something
very special so we just want to say
warmest condolences and and we're with
you all the way it's a tough deal I was
a bad bed level-5 that was a bad group
that's as high as it gets it's a bad
grouping of tornadoes something that's
something incredible the power the
horrible destructive power America is
continuing to make critical progress in
our war against the virus over the
weekend the number of daily new
infections remained flat nationwide flat
hospitalizations are slowing in hotspots
like New York New Jersey Michigan and
Louisiana this is clear evidence that
our aggressive strategy to combat the
virus is working and that Americans are
following the guidelines it's been
incredible what they've done you looked
at the charts and the charts are and the
models from early on predictions we're
100 and 120 thousand people looked like
if they did well they were going to
unfortunately perish and we're going to
be hopefully way way below that number
so that will be a sign of people doing
things right but it's still just a
horrible thing all over the world 184
countries this is all a tribute to our
wonderful health care advisors and
experts who
have been with us right from the
beginning we appreciated so much in fact
dr. foul cheese here maybe I could ask
Tony to say a few words before we go any
further thank you very much Tony please
Thank You mr. president
just a couple of things and then I would
just want to make a comment about
something that happened yesterday you're
gonna hear from dr. Burke soon about the
numbers that we've been talking about
how things are starting to balance off
and I think the more as we go by each
day I think we're gonna see then again I
never like to get ahead of myself or of
dr. Burke's
but it looks like even though we've had
a really bad week last week remember
when I was speaking to you before I was
saying this was really a bad week
there's still gonna be a lot of deaths
but we're starting to see in some areas
now that kind of flattening particularly
in a place that was a hot spot like New
York that's the first thing the second
thing is that I had a really very very
productive conversation with the
Congressional Black Caucus this morning
for about an hour and they really wanted
to know what exactly are we gonna be
doing and the immediate as well is the
long range about the health disparities
and the discrepancies both in infection
and in poor outcome in the minorities in
general but specifically
african-american and I mean I made it
very clear to them that what we have to
do is focus on getting the resources
where the vulnerable are to be able to
get testing done to be able to get the
appropriate identification wear a proper
and we're appropriate to isolate and
contact trace if we can but also to help
mitigate in a community that is is
suffering and suffering much more
disproportionately so I just wanted to
get that of the way
the other point I wanted to make is that
I I had an interview yesterday that I
was asked a hypothetical question and
hypothetical questions sometimes can get
you into some difficulty because it's
what would have or could have the nature
of the hypothetical question was if in
fact we had mitigated earlier good lives
have been saved and the answer to my
question was as I always do and I'm do
right now perfectly honestly say yes I
mean obviously if you mitigation helps
I've been up here many times telling you
that mitigation works
so if mitigation works and you instigate
it and and you initiate it earlier you
will probably have saved more lives
if you initiated it later you probably
would have lost more lives you initiate
it at a certain time that was taken as a
way that maybe somehow something was at
fault here so let me tell you from my
experience and I can only speak from my
own experience is that we have been
talking before any meetings that we had
about the pros and the cons the
effectiveness or not of strong
mitigations so discussions were going on
mostly among the medical people about
what that would mean the first and only
time that dr. Burks and I went in and
formally made a recommendation to the
president to actually have a quote shut
down in the sense of not really shut
down but to really have strong
mitigation we discussed it obviously
they would be concerned by some that in
fact that might have some negative
consequences nonetheless the president
listened to the recommendation and went
to the mitigation the next second time
that I went with dr. Burks into the
president and said 15 days are not
enough we need to go 30 days obviously
there were people who had a problem with
that because of the potential secondary
effects nonetheless at that time the
president went with the health
recommendations and we extended it
another 30 days so I could only tell you
what I know and what my recommendations
were but clearly as happens all the time
there were interpretations of that
response to a hypothetical question that
I just thought it would be not very nice
for me to clarify because they didn't
have the chance to clarify thank you
you know I to be honest with you I don't
even remember what the date was I can
just tell you the first and only time
that I went in and said we should do
mitigation strongly the response was yes
we'll do it no the travel restriction is
separate that was whether or not we
wanted to go into a mitigation stage of
15 days of mitigation the travel was
another recommendation when we went in
and said we probably should be doing
that and the answer was yes and then
another time was we should do it with
Europe and the answer was yes and the
next time we should do it with the UK
and the answer was yes no it wasn't that
was the wrong choice of words you know
what it was when people discuss not
necessarily in front of the president
when people discuss they say well you
know this is gonna have maybe a harmful
effect on this or on that so it was a
poor choice of words there wasn't
anybody saying no you shouldn't do that
everything I do is voluntarily please
don't even imply that statistics I
happen to write a couple of them down if
you look at statistics so one January 6
that's long before the dates you're
talking about
there were CDC issued a travel notice
for Wuhan China
a notice before there was even a
confirmed case of the virus in the
United States that's on January 6
there's all documented because we have
so much fake news I like to document
things January 6th
long before the dates we're talking
about CDC issued travel notice to Wuhan
for Wuhan on January 11th we have zero
cases in the United States zero we don't
have any cases so there are no cases
reported that we know if this is January
11th the CDC issued a level one travel
notice health for health while there
were still no confirmed cases so we had
zero cases people want me to act I'm
supposed to close down the economy the
just economy and the history of the
world and we don't have one case
confirmed in the United States that's
January 11th On January 17th to CDC
began implementing Public Health entry
screenings at three major US airports
that receive the greatest volume of
passengers from Wuhan at my instructions
there was not a single case of the
corona virus in the United States so on
January 17th there wasn't a case and the
fake news is saying oh he didn't act
fast enough well you remember what
happened because when I did act I was
criticized by Nancy Pelosi by sleepy Joe
Biden I was criticized by every but in
fact I was called xenophobic I was
asking Biden to please define that for
me I was called other things by
Democrats and some others not too many
others actually so that by the media
definitely now on January 21st is long
before the time we're talking because
when Tony Tony is talking I believe he's
talking about the end of February on
January 21st ok still early there was
one case of the virus at that time we
call it the Wuhan virus right
Wuhan there was one case in the whole
United States we have one case this is
all documented it all comes from you a
lot of it comes from you people on
January 21st the CDC activated an
emergency operation center there was
just one case one person that's why that
ad was such a phony there was one person
in the United States you know they use
it there's only one person that Sabre
was made at that time one case in the
whole United States one case I'm
supposed to shut down the government the
biggest the biggest economy in the
history of the world shut it down we
have one case seven cases were on
January 31st now in January 21st there
was a case not one person had died you
heard that Steve right not one person so
we have this massive country the United
States of America we have the greatest
economy in the world big
than China's by a lot right because of
what we've done over the last three and
a half years prior to the virus but
including the virus so we have the
biggest economy the greatest economy
we've ever had the highest employment
numbers the best employment numbers best
unemployment numbers also the best of
everything so on January 31st think of
it not one person has died not one
nobody that not one John you I don't
think you'll find any this is reported
by CDC confirmed by the news which
doesn't mean anything to me because they
don't tell the truth but CDC reported
January 31st not one person has died and
I issued a travel restriction from China
think of it so nobody died and I issued
you can't get earlier than that so we
have nobody died and I said China you
can't come in I'm sorry because I saw
what was going on wasn't so much what I
was told it was that I saw what was
going on and I didn't like it but I
didn't speak to Tony about didn't speak
to very many people about it I didn't
like it so what did I do
ready January 31st in the United States
not one person had died because of the
again the Wuhan virus so I issued travel
restrictions and that date even though
nobody died and I got brutalized over it
by the press because I was way too early
I shouldn't have done it
brutalized by the press but you know
sort of I've been brutalized for the
last four years I used to do well before
I decided to join for politics but I
guess I'm doing okay because to the best
of my knowledge I'm the president of the
United States despite the things that
are said so then first mandatory
quarantine in more than 50 years we did
first mandatory in 50 years the same
restrictions that the Democrats and the
media called xenophobic now Joe Biden
said he's a racist call me a racist
because I said we're shutting down entry
from China
we're shutting it down he called me
xenophobic and he called me a racist and
other things since then on a Friday
night two weeks ago Joe Biden issued say
it wasn't him he didn't write it I'm
sure he doesn't even know that it was
issued but the people from his campaign
who was smart people that write there's
little PR releases a pretty smart
reasonably good nothing best but they're
not bad but they issued a statement
saying that Joe Biden agrees that the
press that President Trump was right to
close it down to China now he did that
now he issued it on a Friday night we've
all heard about that John Friday nights
right in fact his was later Friday night
than I ever released mine on Friday
nights okay so he did he did it pretty
late I mean you know like get 11 o'clock
in the evening or something you know
it's pretty late anyway so joe biden
issued and it's one of those things but
in February Nancy Pelosi said we should
come to Chinatown this is late February
come to Chinatown we think it's very
safe come here let's say I'll have the
big parade china town parade probably
referring to San Francisco and that's it
but I took this action early and so the
story in The New York Times is a total
fake it's a fake newspaper and they
write fake stories and someday hopefully
in five years when I'm not here those
papers are all going out of business
because nobody's going to want to read
them but now they like them because they
wrote about me now with that I have a
couple of interesting we have a few
clips that we're just going to put up we
could turn the lights a little bit lower
I think you'll find them interesting and
then we'll answer some questions I'll
ask you some questions because you're so
guilty but forget it
but most importantly we're going to get
back on to the reason we're here which
is the success we're having okay
please you can put it on thank you
people should be more concerned right
now with the flu illness contract
product people are concerned about the
corona virus because they're hearing a
lot of news about it right now but the
reality is comparing it to the flu for
example it's not even close to being at
that stage what if it is worse is this a
moment where maybe countries put
politics aside a little bit of pride
aside and do we have US officials should
US professionals such as yourself get
involved how worried should Americans be
about coronavirus toward a virus is not
gonna cause a major is the United States
well we've asked them to accelerate
whatever they're doing in terms of a
vaccine we will be suspending all travel
from Europe to the United States for the
next 30 days to unleash the full power
of the federal government in this effort
today I am officially declaring a
national emergency Medicare patients can
now visit any doctor by phone or video
conference at no additional cost the
first 1 million masks will be available
immediately as there were more cases and
it was clear that it was spreading out
of China where it originated the
president took this move that he was
widely criticized for by Democrats and
even some Republicans at the time which
was he halted a number of flights from
China into the US the idea was to hold
the spread of the disease
keep transmissions to a minimum he was
accused of xenophobia he was accused of
making a racist move at the end of the
day it was probably effective because it
did actually take a pretty aggressive
measure against the spread of the virus
his team is on it they've been
responsive late at night early in the
morning and they've thus far been doing
everything that they can do and I want
to say thank you and I want to say that
I appreciate it he returns calls he
reaches out
he's been proactive we got that mercy
ship down here in Los Angeles that was
directly because he sent it down here
2000 medical units came to the state of
California these FMS these these field
medical stations and that's been very
very helpful the president has been
outstanding through all this the vice
president's been outstanding members of
the coronavirus task force very
responsive we get asked if we could have
New Jersey could have access to a piece
of the beds that are on the US and as
comfort and the president came back
called the a short a few minutes before
I walked in here to say indeed they
would grant that to New Jersey so that's
a big step for us in addition to all the
other capacity that news is literally
hot off the press and I thank the
president and vice president who are on
the call together
president Trump approved Arizona's
requests for a presidential major
disaster declaration I want to thank the
president for a quick turnaround we
requested this on a Wednesday and we had
approval by Saturday morning and we are
grateful to the administration for their
continued support and responsiveness
well first of all I want to thank the
president the vice president for doing a
really good job of communicating with
all the governors so we could give you
hundreds of clips like that from
governors including Democratic or
Democrat as I call them governors which
is actually the correct term we could
give you hundreds of clips just like
that we have them we didn't want this to
go on too long but I just want to say
it's you know it's very sad when people
write false stories like in that case I
guess it was gotten mostly from the New
York Times which is
highly I mean if you had libel laws they
would have been out of business even
before they'll end up going out of
business so it's too bad but we could
have given you saw the statements we
have hundreds of statements hundreds of
statements including from Democrats and
Democrat governors and if you look they
were all saying we need ventilators we
need you don't hear ventilators anymore
they have all the ventilators they need
which we were right about we said you're
asking for too many you don't need that
and in all fairness these two people
right here dr. Burke's doctor ouchy they
said I don't think they need that many
ventilators I said I agree at one point
and I'm not knocking New York for this
but they're asking you remember 40,000
ventilators and that's more than they
have all over the country and we got
them a lot of ventilators and nobody's
complained we got them as you know
beautiful we built hospital rooms all
over the country the governor of
Louisiana John bel Edwards was very nice
he said you know what you don't have to
build the second hospital because good
news is happening they're not able to
fill the beds they needed two hospitals
we built one it was perfect we're
getting we're just starting the other I
called him up I said you think we should
build the second one I don't think
you're gonna need it he said let me get
back he got back we didn't need it with
Governor Cuomo in all good spirit and
faith he wanted to have the Jacob Javits
Center done and we built 2900 incredible
beds incredible then we make it we made
it covet and or to be exactly accurate
kovat 19 and which was a lot of work we
had to change the ductwork we had a seal
up certain areas we had to put areas of
roof top things over the beds we did a
lot of work and we had it but they never
really had too much in stored and they
called also mayor de Blasio rightfully
he called he said would it be possible
to get more medical help so now not only
are we building facilities were they're
asking us to help because they're unable
to man it and we got him to help we got
a lot of help then when the Javits
Center wasn't used much and then as you
know the Mersey we took the merci and we
took the Comfort and we made them both
Los Angeles and New York we made them
kovat adaptable which was not easy to do
and we didn't get almost any people sent
there they didn't need him at the
beginning because they didn't need it
for anything but this because there were
fewer accidents we were motorcycles for
everything and what we did was like an
incredible job but they didn't need him
it turned out they were there who we
were ready you know the expression they
have an expression ready willing and
able we were ready willing and able but
the Army Corps of Engineers did was a
miracle what what FEMA did was a miracle
what the doctors did so I got a call two
days ago from the mayor of New York he
said could you help us even more with
medical personnel and we sent I think
was 448 doctors nurses and respiratory
experts real experts and I got a call
from the mayor and he said I want to
tell you incredible these people are
incredible he said they lifted the
spirits of the hospital workers from New
York City like nothing I've ever seen he
see was unbelievable what he said was
really appreciated and I let them know
that I let the military people he said
they went in there so brave so
incredible they lifted the spirits of
everybody we did all of this work but
when you read the phony stories you know
buddy nobody acknowledges this and it
doesn't have to be acknowledged from my
standpoint but it does have to be
acknowledged from the great work that
these doctors nurses the Army Corps of
Engineers Fame all these people they've
done this incredible job and they
shouldn't be abused because you take a
look at what's happened nobody's asking
for ventilators except outside of our
country outside of our country they're
calling me every country they're calling
me so many countries and I'm gonna try
and help them because we have thousands
of ventilators being built but nobody's
asking for ventilators nobody's asking
for beds because we built hospitals I
think we built 20,000 beds in a period
of a couple of weeks
the job they've done is incredible with
all of that being said I'm getting along
very well with the governor's and if I
wouldn't Mike Pence had a call today
with the governors and it was like a ten
I said how was it he said it's 2/10 he
is one of my expressions actually but he
said it was like a ten and I'm sure you
people were probably on the Colo that
you weren't supposed to be but you were
sitting in somebody's office listening
to it because every time we have these
and you know and you would know that for
weeks those calls have been very good
but there wasn't a raised voice there
wasn't even a statement of like we think
you should do this or that I heard it
was like a just a perfect phone call it
might not be reported that way they'll
say I thought that somebody maybe
slightly raised didn't even raise the
voice my only my only point is send this
because I want to get back to why we're
here the press has not treated these
incredible people who have done such a
great job they haven't treated unfairly
they're way off we were way ahead of
schedule and remember this because the
time sir was a fake but everything
remember this everything we did I was
criticized because I was too early if I
waited longer it would have been you
would have incurred if I went way early
if I went three months earlier I would
have been criticized you know criticized
for being way too early so with all of
that being said we understand it I think
I've educated a lot of people as to the
press and I would love to be able to say
that we have a very honest press
honestly John there'd be nothing I would
be more proud of if the press would work
and I don't mind being criticized but
not when they're wrong not when people
have done a great job yes I've never
seen a video like that play in this
it looks a bit like a campaign ad who
who produced that video well that was
done by a group in the office and it was
done just by we just put some flips
together I could give you I'll bet you I
have over a hundred more clips even
better than them they were just pieced
together over the last two hours that
was just oh we have far better than that
that's nothing compared to somebody
who's produced here in the White House
yeah this was done by Dan and a group of
people and they just put it together in
a period of probably less than two hours
you'll need to do that because we're
getting fake news and I like to have it
corrected they're saying what a great
job we're doing and the mita these are
the governors of California Governor of
New Jersey governor of New York look in
New York we work very close with Andrew
in New York ventilators were going to be
a problem we didn't they didn't have a
problem we got them tremendous numbers
of thousands but we got them tremendous
number of ventilate you don't hear
ventilators their problem beds were
going to be a problem I mean I'm happy
about it the Javits Center which is
incredible is almost empty because they
don't need it that's good news not bad
news I've you know I'm not saying gee I
wish more people were there I don't want
more people there we brought in the boat
we brought in the comfort and the
comfort was originally not supposed to
be for this at all the corona virus are
not supposed to be for that at all they
called they said could we have it that
was a number of weeks ago we said we
don't think you need it but if you need
it we'll do it then they said could you
get the medical personnel to run the
Javits Center could you get the medical
personnel to run the ship we said if
it's necessary we will and we did with
there were military personnel that's the
ones that Mayor DeBlasio was so great to
in terms of his statements I mean I
really appreciated his statements he was
so impressed with them and I am to the
level of genius and bravery they're
great people the military people and we
pieced that together I would say it took
less than two hours who was done in st
this was my government employees by
people here at the White House this
campaign-style
all they did was took some flips and
they just ran them for you and the
reason they did is to keep you honest no
I don't think that's gonna work it's not
gonna have any impact
but just think of it you heard the clips
you heard what I said
they said I acted late on closing down
the country some people wish we never
closed it down now if we didn't we would
have lost hundreds of thousands of
people you know interestingly so I'm
against it we did the right to
everything we did was right if we would
have closed a mix along the way here you
think everything you did was right
well look governor should have had
ventilators they chose not to have them
we were able to get on ventilators you
haven't heard other than you know there
was a lot of panic a lot of scream will
you 1 ventilate they got the ventilators
you don't have that anymore
and the surge is supposed to be coming
now and if they do need ventilators John
we've got almost 10,000 that are ready
to rock we have people standing with
those ventilators right now if you
needed 2,000 in New York which you don't
but if you did we can have them here in
less than 24 hours we're ready to rock
this was a great this was a great
military and beyond that operation let's
get back to the regular well should we
get back to the regular we could talk
about this but all I'm doing is this I
could have given you like those are four
or five clips that we just play for you
I could have given you hundreds of
people I mean Gavin was on television
two days ago with one of your
competitors singing prayer he says look
you know the question was asked in a
negative way he said look I know what
you want to say but want me to say but
he's been really good it's hard for me
to say that in fact it's impossible for
me to say Gavin Newsom of the Governor
of California
I have many clips from many I have some
clips from Anthony that I didn't want to
put up which were really good I think
Anthony would be the first one to say
when I closed the country to China when
I closed the China banned whatever you
want to call it Anthony said I saved a
lot of lives by doing that I mean am I
correct I don't want to put words in
Anthony's mouth by the way and I like
him today I walk in I hear I'm gonna
fire him I'm not firing I think he's a
wonderful
a fire i retweeted somebody Peugeot
they said fire doesn't matter did you
notice that we know that somebody's
opinion oh that is an opinion and you
know I was told about that I said I'm
not firing effective you ask your
friends in the office and the public
relations office I was immediately
called upon that and I said no I like
him I think he's terrific because this
was a person's view not everybody's
happy with Anthony not everybody's happy
with everybody but I will tell you we
have done a job the likes of which
nobody has ever done the mobilization
getting of equipment all of the things
we've done nobody's ever done a job like
this we have 50 governors and
territories by the way people don't ever
mention that we have territories we have
50 governors and territories and many of
those governors are Democrats and they
can't find anything to complain about
and honestly many of them didn't do
their jobs I'll let you know someday
let's see what happens but I make let
you know who's not doing their job I can
tell you the ones that are good both
Republican and Democrat and the ones who
don't know what they're doing but we
help some of the ones that don't know
what they're doing they should have had
their own stockpiles and now if they
want we can build them stockpiles of
ventilators the hardest thing as a
ventilator because it's expensive it
takes a while to get we got him and
nobody believed we did now many of the
governors were asking for far too many
and we said they were asking for far too
many we talked and we said you said very
strongly that they just don't need that
me you said they don't need that many
beds
Deborah so that's it Steve good yeah
what happened from the beginning I don't
know what it is exactly but if I put
somebody's opinion up you don't I don't
mind controversy I think controversy is
a good thing not a bad thing but I want
it to be honest controversy now when I
got a call I got a call not very quickly
and nobody you know saw that as being
any big deal they said how are you doing
with dr. Fatih I said I'm doing great
and I didn't talk to dr. fetcher even or
until we just got here
dr. Falchi asked one of the people if he
could get up and speak and he did and
they totally misinterpreted him I saw
what they did he said the question was
hypothetical but what he was just
acknowledging is that lives would have
been saved if the mitigation practices
were put into place earlier that seems
obvious do you not agree with that yes I
think what he really is saying though
but how could you have done it look I
just went over stats with you right here
right here
how do you close it up you have no
deaths and no cases on January 11th
doctor would you recommend closing the
United States of America oh this must be
terrible how many cases do we have none
how many deaths do we have none January
17th go back another week on January
17th this is ten days before I did the
little bit less than ten days before I
did the band I did a ban on China I
think that was easy I didn't did a ban
on Europe and a lot of people said that
was an incredible thing to do because
you look at Spain and by the way we're
doing very well because when you look at
all of those flat graphs and you add it
all up the United States is very low and
per capita were very low we're doing
very well but how do you close up the
United States of America so on January 6
no deaths when january leavens know this
and note no cases on January 17th no
cases no cases no deaths I'm supposed to
close up the United States of America
when I have no cases the middle of March
should you close it down I've closed
down from China excuse me I closed it
down from China and by the way some
people think I should have waited longer
and maybe written it out I disagree with
them okay but it was thought up I mean
that was an alternative you know there
are a lot of people that would have said
let's write it out now I'll give you the
good news if I would have done that it
would have been I think catastrophic
because their numbers are Anthony 1.6 to
2.2 million people would have died if we
tried to do that and I did this last
time cut it in half don't say 2.2
million cut it in more than half say a
million people died well that's much
more than the Civil War
cut it in half take the million and cut
it in half that's 500,000 people would
have died now that number we would have
reached okay that would have been easy
to reach if we did nothing so we did the
right thing and our timing was very good
but here's the one thing and you have to
say this when you ask me why didn't you
do this how come when I did the ban on
China and some very very instituted some
very tough things
how come Nancy Pelosi a month later is
in Chinatown saying let's all March this
is not going to happen how come we have
many of the experts from CNN and many
other networks if you call CNN a network
I don't personally but we have CNN we
have many other places and they're all
saying he doesn't need to do it he
doesn't need to do it all I'm saying is
this how do you close down the greatest
economy in the history of the world when
on January 17th
you have no cases and no death when on
January 21st you have one case and no
death one case to think of that now
we're supposed to close down the country
but here's what happened when on January
31st I instituted the band Joe Biden
went crazy he said you don't need the
band you he didn't go crazy like he just
he didn't even know what the hell the
band was but he so he didn't go crazy
but he did say he did call me Xenophon
wait a minute
he called me xenophobic he called me a
racist because he has since apologized
and he said I did the right thing so
when you say why didn't you this every
Democrat thought I made a mistake when I
did it I saved tens of thousands maybe
hundreds of thousands of lives paper you
bought the argument that you bought
yourself some time you didn't you didn't
use it to ramp up testing so you so
disgraceful it's so disgraceful the way
you said it
let me just listen I just went over it I
just went over
nobody thought we should do it and what
I did it we did what you do what do you
do when you have no case in a whole
United States when you excuse me you
reported it zero cases zero deaths On
January 17 Daniel I said in Jenny on
January 30 and in fact we'll give you a
list what we did in fact part of it was
up there we did a lot you know you're a
fake you know that your whole network
the way you cover it is fake and most of
it and not all of you but the people are
wise to you that's why you have a lower
lower approval rating than you've ever
had before times probably three and when
you asked me that question let me ask
you this why didn't Biden why didn't why
did Biden apologize why did he write a
letter of apology you know that's very
important why did the Democrats think
that I acted too quickly you know why
because they really thought that I acted
too quickly we have done a great job now
I could have I could have kept it open
and I could have done what some
countries are doing they're getting beat
up pretty badly I could have kept it
open I thought of keeping it open
because nobody's ever heard of closing
down a country let alone the United
States of America but if I would have
done that we would have had hundreds of
thousands of people that would right now
be dead we've done this right and we we
really we really have done this right
the problem is the press doesn't cover
it the way it should be good one more
question Steve go there's a debate
what the thority you have to order the
country reopened what authority well I
have the ultimate authority but we're
gonna get into that in a minute we're
going to just finish this up we're going
to tell you about other things that
we've done right but I will say this had
we said let's just keep going and let's
not do it closing whether it's 2.2 that
they at one point predicted as an
outside or one point six at a lower
number you cut it all the way down to
six or seven or eight hundred thousand
take just a fraction of the number that
could have happened it literally would
have been more than the civil war it
would have been a disaster
so the minimum number was a hundred
thousand and I think I feel pretty good
that we're gonna be substantially below
Anthony the hundred thousand and I hope
we will alright so today the Department
of Health and Human Service is
announcing five new contracts to procure
large numbers of additional ventilators
under the defense production Act which
we used a lot by the way which you
didn't like to talk about in addition to
the 1,300 we received today we received
today 1,300 additional ventilators now
we're probably not going to need them
but we can add that to our stockpile
which is very big and we can move it
around should the surge take place and
should it be a very substantial surge
we're ready to were ready to rock
the contracts are with General Electric
Hill ROM Medtronic rest med and VY air
combined with the DPA contracts that we
announced last week with General Motors
and Phillips and two other contracts
with Hamilton and Zoll we're adding six
thousand one hundred and ninety
ventilators to the strategic national
stockpile of which we have a lot already
thousands close to ten thousand but this
will be added by May 8th another 29,000
by the end of May and more than 120,000
total we will have by the end of the
year now we're going to help other
countries we're going to help States if
they need it we may help some states
stockpile you know they're supposed to
buy their own stockpile they have state
stockpiles is supposed to be using that
and unfortunately most of the states
weren't there and a lot of people didn't
want to talk about it but they weren't
there
we will talk about it the right time if
you want to I at this point I'm more
focused on getting past this nightmare
of epidemic or a pandemic anything you
want to call it we got to get past it
no one who has needed a ventilators not
gotten a ventilator think of that you
know you're all about ventilators
ventilators we need ventilators because
they didn't have them because the state
should have had him no one who is needed
a ventilator has not gotten a ventilator
no one who has needed a hospital bed has
been denied a hospital but that's not
even really our responsibility now if we
can help we're going to do it but that's
where the Army Corps of Engineers did a
such a great job we built over 20,000
beds in fact we built thousands more
than we've actually needed to be safe we
wanted to be safe and we really they
rose to this incredible occasion I mean
we built more beds than we thought we
thought in Louisiana we were going heavy
and again when I call the governor I
said maybe we shouldn't build that
second hospital because we don't want to
build it if you don't need it he called
back he said I don't think we're gonna
need it
they had a thousand rooms a thousand
beds and they used a lot of them but
they didn't need the other one so we
stopped it because we don't want to
waste but we're prepared to build
thousands more should we need it I don't
think we're gonna need it because it
looks like we're plateauing and maybe
even in many cases coming down in
addition we've ordered a total of 60
mobile decontamination contamination
systems so the decontamination system
from Patil in Ohio is an incredible
thing because it takes the masks and up
to twenty times you can decontaminate a
mask and I've been asking from the
beginning why can't we sterilize and
sanitize these masks and it turned out
we can and there was a great company in
Ohio they sent us some great equipment
and they're doing that now and now we're
going to have more than 33 million n95
masks per week will be cleaned
decontaminated and it'll be great it's
something that frankly I think people
should have thought of a long time ago
five more flights landed today as part
of the project air bridge our massive
air list
operation to bring personal protective
equipment into the United States which
is now delivered nearly half a million
n95 masks 370 million gloves 25 million
surgical masks and four-point point nine
million gown so we have millions of
gowns gloves masks all surgical
equipment coming in should the states
need it now the state that the states
are supposed to be buying their own
stuff but should they need it we are
ready to give them because we're
building up our stockpile again like
crazy remember I am I and you saw the
stories I inherited this administration
Mike myself the whole administration we
inherited a stockpile where the
cupboards were bare there was nothing
and I say it and I'll say it again just
like we didn't have ammunition we didn't
have medical supplies we didn't have
ventilators we didn't have a lot of
things that should have been had and you
can read your own stories on that
because you know what happened they
didn't want to spend the money but we
did to date we've facilitated the supply
of more than thirty eight million n95
masks nationwide this week we'll be
sending two million n95 masks to the
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania the Vice
President will go into more detail he's
got great detail on that and I think
it's a pretty amazing story we have a
lot of masks already in stock and we
have more coming we're further expanding
hospital surge capacity in key areas of
the opening and we have a portion of
certain VA hospitals and non-veteran
coronavirus patients including at the
East Orange New Jersey Medical Center as
well as facilities in Manhattan in
Brooklyn they're ready they're able
they're beautiful
hopefully we won't need too many of them
because frankly we built everything that
the governor's wanted and in many cases
it's too much we told them it was too
much but we wanted to err on the side of
caution the United States has now
conducted nearly 3 million tests for the
virus 3 million the most of any nation
we are performing approximately 115,000
tests every single day and our rate of
testing is especially high in areas
hardest hit by the virus if you look and
that's really and it
hit some areas the virus very very hard
for example per capita testing in New
York is higher than the rest of the
world the NIH CDC and FDA are also
currently validating several antibody
tests that will allow us to determine
whether someone has already had the
virus and potentially become immune to
infection we're looking at that the
antibody tests are can be very
interesting over the next short well a
lot of things are being developed as we
speak in the race to develop effective
treatments the drug company Gilead
announced that its drug where MD severe
has shown promising results very
promising in compassionate use settings
in addition the FDA has just granted
emergency u-thor authorization for a
device that removes certain proteins
from the bloodstream possibly preventing
a patient's immune system from
overreacting to the virus and damaging
vital organs which is a big problem
furthermore over the last seven days my
administration has deployed roughly 28
million doses of hydroxychloroquine from
our national stockpile we have millions
of doses that we bought and many people
are using it all over the country and
just recently a friend of mine told me
he got better because of the use of that
that drug so who knows and you've
combined it with z-pak you combine it
with zinc depending on your doctor's
recommendation and having some very good
results I'll tell you think of anybody
recommended at other than me will be
used all over the place to be honest
with you I think the fact that I
recommend it and I properly set it back
a lot but it's a lot of good things are
happening with it a lot of good tests
scientists are also pursuing a blood
therapy known as convalescent plasma
convalescent plasma this therapy uses
antibodies from the blood of recovered
patients to treat those who are sick and
this is something that actually is a
very old procedure but it's done in a
very modern way during this difficult
time we're also working to ensure that
the 2020 census is completed safely and
accuracy we may be asking for an
extension because obviously they can't
be doing very much right now
they wouldn't even be allowed to do it
so the census we're gonna be asking for
a delay a major delay I think how can
you possibly be knocking on doors for a
long period of time now the Census
Bureau recently made the decision to
temporary suspend its field operation
data collection activities to help stop
the spread in addition while millions of
Americans continue to complete their
questionnaire online the Census Bureau
says Congress for a 120 extension I
don't know that you even have to ask
them this is called an act of God this
is called a situation that has to be
they have to give in I think 120 days
isn't nearly enough my administration is
also taking bold action to help American
workers on Friday Americans began
receiving the cash payments authorized
by a historic two trillion dollar relief
bill by the end of the week nearly 80
million Americans will receive a total
of 147 billion dollars and from what the
secretary of the Treasury tells me
that's very much untime and going very
nicely he'll be speaking in a moment in
payments these payments go directly into
the banks and the bank accounts of these
people millions of additional payments
will follow the typical family of four
will receive $3,400 that's for a family
of four that's something additionally
through our paycheck protection program
which is a tremendous success and they
should extend it and increase it this
has been a tremendous success so
successful that the banks should take it
a little bit longer to distribute the
money but it's going rapidly we've now
processed over two hundred billion
dollars in loans to help small
businesses retain their workers now we
urgently need lawmakers to set aside the
partisan agendas and to replenish this
program with new funds because it's
really something that has been an
incredible success and they need more
money to keep it going to take care of
these businesses and keep a note keep
them open I want to thank the many
governor's health professional
scientists and business leaders for
their incredible hard work and input
over the past month and even long beyond
a month Mike I would say you know we've
been working together with a lot of them
for it seems like forever I've been
having many discussions with my tea
and top experts and we're very close to
completing a plan to open our country
hopefully even ahead of schedule and
that's so important we will soon
finalize new and very important
guidelines to give governor's the
information they need to start safely
opening their states my administration's
plan and corresponding guidelines will
give the American people the confidence
they need to begin returning to normal
life that's what we want we want to have
our country open we want to return to
normal life our country is going to be
open and it's going to be successfully
opened and we'll be explaining over a
very short number of days exactly what
is going to be we've also as you
probably heard developed a committee
we're actually calling at a number of
committees with the most prominent
people in the country the most
successful people in the various fields
that we'll be announcing them tomorrow
this weekend the United States also
helped facilitate an unprecedented
agreement among the 23 nations of OPEC
plus that's OPEC plus additional energy
producing nations representing many of
the world's largest oil-producing
countries to stabilize all markets and
we have in fact and I think you've seen
a big stabilization over the last couple
of days together countries around the
world will cut our oil production by
approximately 20 million barrels people
are saying ten million but we think that
the number that they'll actually hit is
going to be closer to 20 million barrels
a day and that will help a lot with
saving jobs all over Texas and Oklahoma
and North Dakota and many of other other
of our big energy states this historic
action will help nearly 11 million
American workers who are supported by
the US oil and gas industry it's a very
monumental agreement I want to thank
Saudi Arabia and the king of Saudi
Arabia Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia both
I want to thank President Putin of
Russia and I want to thank a very good
friend of mine man who's become a friend
of mine the President of Mexico showed
great flexibility President Lopez
Obrador he showed great flexibility and
and tremendous intelligence doing what
he did it was not that easy for him and
I want to thank Mexico and the president
this is a very historic deal very
historic so we'll see how it all goes in
this time and challenge and we are
certainly in a time probably like we
haven't been in many many decades we are
strengthened and sustained by the bonds
of love and loyalty that unites all
Americans I'm so proud of the American
people everywhere you look you see the
patriotism of our people shining through
and the courage of our doctors and
nurses on the front lines in the
dedication of our food supply workers
and in the commitment of every citizen
to achieving victory over the virus
that's what's going to happen it's going
to happen sooner than people think and
we're gonna be smart about it very very
smart about it we're gonna be safe about
it we're going to be listening also to
the great doctors and medical
professionals together we're beating
back the invisible enemy and we're
paving the way for great resurgence
really a great resurgence for American
prosperity our country wants to go back
they want to go back to work they're
going to go back safely and that's what
we want I'd like now to ask vice
president pence to say a few words
followed by dr. Fauci and dr. Burks I
think before we before we do this
because I know there's an emergency
where they want Steve to come so what
I'll do is I'll ask Steve to come up
secretary of the Treasury you can talk a
little bit and then maybe take a couple
of questions about what's happening
tell them the success we're having thank
you very much
Thank You mr. president and mr. vice
president as you announced we are very
pleased that we are ahead of schedule on
delivering the economic impact payments
these were what was known as the checks
in the mail that we want to deliver in
direct direct deposit this is ahead of
schedule we started processing those
last Friday we expect that over 80
million hardworking Americans will get
the direct deposit by this Wednesday and
we know how important that is to all of
those hardworking Americans many of
which are at home not working at the
moment if you do not receive them by
Wednesday on Wednesday we will be
launching at irs.gov click on irs.gov go
to get your payment if you filed a tax
return in 2018 and 19 or 19 have that
information available you'll be able to
ID yourself you'll be able to put in
your direct deposit information and
within several days we will
automatically deposit the money into
your account we want to do as much of
this electronically as we can it's very
important in this day and age it's more
secure and you don't have to go to the
bank if you were a social security
beneficiary you do not need to do
anything you will get a direct deposit
if you have not filed and did not need
to file a 2,000 or 18 and 19 return you
can go to irs.gov now and enter your
information and authenticate yourself so
again we are very pleased that that is
ahead of schedule I'd also like to
announce the progress we're making on
the new SBA program the PPP let me just
remind everybody this is a brand-new
program that is now one week old we have
distributed and confirmed two hundred
and thirty billion of loans to over
4,600 lenders participating that is
multiples in multiples of anything that
the SBA has ever done and in one year
before and I especially want to thank
the broad-based community banks that are
participating again over 4,600 banks if
you haven't tagged your loan processed
you will get a process this week as the
president said we've gone back to
Congress and asked them for more money
to make sure that every business has
access to this let me also comment for
the states we are distributing out half
the money this week to the states that's
a week ahead of time and we'll deliver
the other half of the money to the
state's next week and then let me just
finally comment we've been very working
very closely with the Federal Reserve
last week we announced expanded
facilities and new facilities that total
2.3 trillion dollars of liquidity and in
particular I just like to highlight a
Main Street lending facility that will
be for companies between one worker in
10,000 people so midsize businesses and
also a municipal facility for states and
local governments to be able to access
funds given the shortages that they have
so with that I'm happy to answer any
questions to seizures
thank you sir both speaker Pelosi and
minority leader Schumer have said that
they're in negotiations with you right
now on additional funding for these
small business loans that package
leader McConnell though has said that
nothing should be added to the package
that should just be specific to small
business loans what is the opinion of
your administration should there be some
sort of horse trading here or should it
just be small business or the
president's view and the vice
president's in my view is this was a
bipartisan program this SBA program it
wasn't a Republican program it wasn't a
Democrat program was a bipartisan
program we've committed to small
businesses we should top up that program
now I know the Democrats want to talk
about more money for hospitals and
states right now we're just sending the
money out to the hospitals and states
they haven't come close to using that
money and I know the President and
vice-presidents have said once we get
the SBA done we can go into another
funding bill the president's talked
about potentially adding infrastructure
and other things we think there is a
likelihood we will need more money and
we will we will sit down and try to get
a bipartisan bill but this is important
we deliver on small businesses 50
percent of the people work for small
businesses hey sir what's the emergency
that the president said you had to go
for you had an emergency negotiation
over this bill yeah well we're because
we don't want to run out of money we've
used about 220 billion of the 350
billion we don't want to run out of that
money we don't want to create panics
that people won't get it so that's why
we want out we want to top that up and
we've asked for another 250 billion for
that program and again let me just
remind you every dollar we spend in this
program we save a dollar of unemployment
insurance so even though we're asking
for 250 billion it really won't cost
that much did you have concerns about
lifting the guidelines too soon what's
the economic impact I understand the
economic argument for getting people
back to work obviously but what's the
economic risk of lifting them too early
and seeing a spike in cases well first
there's economic risks in both
directions we reviewed with the
president today a very broad list of
over a hundred businesspeople that are
gonna help advise the President on what
needs to be done to reopen the economy
we want to make sure and again the
combination of economic impact payments
small business payments enhanced
unemployment insurance the president
made very clear we want to make sure
that hardworking Americans have
liquidity while we wait to reopen the
government so do you believe the
government should be a trio are you the
country excuse me
opened on May 1 I've had discussions
with the president I know he's
considering it and I believe he's going
to make a decision later and the way
everything has to be safe
my advice is as soon as it's ready to
open and based upon the medical
professionals and and again we're
working very closely with the president
and outside business leaders to develop
a plan what you think if you can sketch
for us what we in the economy looks like
do you think it's gonna be everything
else what do you think there over the
next two days because we'll probably be
making a statement about that and
exactly what it looks like I know what
that looks like but I also want to get
the advice in a sense we have some of
the the biggest from every business on
this council we're actually setting up a
number of different councils or
committees I guess you could call them
and we have a lot of smart people I
think that they will give us some also
good advice but no we want to be very
very safe at the same time we got to get
our country open do you think there is a
possibility then that what you do is you
incremental if you think people go back
to rest rose concerts the cinema and I
think we're going to boom I think we're
going to I think it's gonna go quickly
our people want to get back to work and
I think there's a pent up demand like
that hasn't been in a long time
well that's why and that's why you see
the stock market I mean to think that
the stock markets at the level it is
right now with all that this world and
this country has gone and look at the
European Union how badly decimated
they've been look at other countries
look at China by the way I've seen the
numbers look at China look at how these
countries have been just decimated by
this and to think that the stock market
is at this tremendously high number not
that much you know was looking a little
bleak for a while but it hit a certain
point and then started going up I think
that's a great tribute to the fact that
there's a demand yeah mr. president
thank you sir in regards to some of your
tweets earlier today and I think
Steve's question my question to you is
what provision in the Constitution gives
the president the power to open or close
state economies and then provisions
we'll be looking forward to that sir but
following up what happens if you say for
instance we want States to reopen but
California or New York
do not open what would you do ordered
schools closed it's been states that
have ordered businesses like restaurants
because I let that happen because I
would have preferred that I let that
happen but if I wanted to I could have
closed it up but I let that happen and I
like the way they've done it and the
seven that remained really in sort of a
semi lockdown if you look at those
states they've really done a very good
job they're very much different from in
New York or from other places where
they've been hit very hard you open your
schools i order you to yes mr. president
following up on that there are two
consortiums of states today California
Oregon Washington on the west coast
northeastern states
totally representing about a hundred
million people who said they're going to
cooperate and decide wind real they can
decide but what you're trying no not at
all let me just tell you very simp I'm
gonna put it very simply the President
of the United States has the authority
to do what the president has the
authority to do which is very powerful
the President of the United States calls
the shots if we weren't here for the
States you would have had a problem in
this country like you've never seen
before we were here to back them up
and we back and we've more than back
them up we did a job that nobody ever
thought was possible it's a decision for
the President of the United States now
with that being said we're going to work
with the states because it's very
important you have local governments
there pinpoint it it's really you talk
about it's a like a microchip they're
pinpointed we have local government that
hopefully will do a good job and if they
don't do a good job I'd step in so fast
but no they can't do anything without
the approval of the president the
University
so if some states refused to reopen and
you order them to the Tenth Amendment of
the Constitution says all powers that
don't resign the president the Congress
reside in the States
how do you well if some states to refuse
to open I would be I would like to see
that person run for election they're
gonna open to think it all open Palafox
I think that's something that's not
gonna happen they want to open they have
to open they have to get open every one
of those states that people want to go
and they want to now some will be earned
a different situation you have I won't
name States now but I will over the next
two or three days I'm going to be very
specific but you have some states where
this is not the kind of a problem than
it is in New York or Louisiana or
Michigan or other places that got hit
very hard Illinois got hit very hard but
all states want to open and they want to
open as soon as possible but they want
to open safely and so do I yeah please
today the French president in menu and
my corn sentence here we keep the
shutdown in France in the middle of May
does that mean that the US will keep the
ban French got hit very hard France got
hit very hard and again he has to do
what he has to do is friend of mine but
France Spain has just been decimated you
look at what's happened in Italy it's a
very well known fact what happened in
Italy no they were hit very hard
question for secretary Venetian has
everybody that you would like to have
the hundred businesspeople on the
economic counts what have they all been
invited already have they all agreed to
haven't been invited yet we just
reviewed the names with the president
today sectors yes there's basically
there's vertical so every single area of
the economy we wanted to be represented
great one other thing is there anything
else needs to be done to to work on
industry oil industry jobs to save oil
industry jobs after the deal this past
weekend well I think there's always
things so we're working with Larry
Kudlow I mean we we have agree we have
the economic plans for every single part
of the economy obviously in the case of
the oil industry they've been hit
especially hard because you've had both
the the supply issue and you've had the
demand issue for the airlines with the
allocations for the airline so I'm
pleased to say we've worked very hard I
think as you probably have seen we put
out a press release that we have now had
discussions with almost all the airlines
I've personally had discussions with all
the major airline CEOs we specifically
created an exception for small airlines
that we could process very quickly and I
think you'll see very quickly decisions
coming out I'm very pleased with the
discussions we've had very good
see I just want to say we have had
discussion the weight excuse me one
second
we've had very good discussions with the
Airlines very good discussions is it
possible to reopen the economy on made
the first I don't want to say you'll be
hearing over the next few days for this
push in lieu of another stimulus so
again let me just comment I mean
Congress on a bipartisan basis approved
an unprecedented amount of money to help
American workers in American business
because it was no fault of their own
that business was closed down we we have
been very diligently executing on that
you know everybody said it was gonna
take months to get people money we are
executing very quickly we created a
whole new SBA program in a week our job
right now is to execute the 2.3 billion
which we can add several trillion
dollars with the Fed the one area we are
particularly concerned about is the
small business program quite frankly
it's even more incredibly popular and
successful than we anticipated so the
president wants to be very clear we have
money for that and once we get done with
that we will review it the president if
there is more money that needs to be to
support this economy to support
hardworking Americans we will work with
Congress to get that phase four so phase
four the president has has talked about
infrastructure for a long period of time
we've talked about to the extent that
the hospitals need more money because of
the medical issues we'll will monitor
that we want to make sure there are
incentives for restaurants entertainment
people to get back to those types of
things so we'll be looking at very
specifically provisions to stimulate
parts of the economy some of them may be
money issues some of them may be
regulatory issues
just to clarify your understanding of
your authority these are the governor's
just be very specific for instance if a
governor issued a state home when you
say my authority the president's
authority that might because it's not me
this is when somebody's the president of
the United States the authority is total
and that's so it's got to be there you
have a couple of bands of excuse me
excuse me
you have a couple you have a couple of
bands of Democrat governors but they
will agree to it
they will agree to her but the authority
of the President of the United States
having to do with the subject we're
talking about his total we saw in your
video about was the travel ban from
Europe it's part of reality America do
you want to reopen the borders so
there's people from Europe from the UK
at the right time
very good question actually well I'm
gonna have to take a look I wouldn't say
Italy is doing great right now and I
wouldn't say Spain's doing great right
now and we just heard that France is
extending its stay inside order right
stay they've extended it I just see that
and I think for a short period of time
but no when they're back we want to do
it very quickly but we want to make sure
everything's good no right now we have a
very right now we have a very strong
band we're gonna keep it that way until
they heal weeks months what would you I
can tell you that I have to see how are
they doing I mean France just went for
another two days for another two weeks
we have to see John she said that you
took his advice on the question of
mitigation
he made the recommendation you accepted
it you put it in place as you make this
next decision which well that I'm not
sure who really gave me advice on the
band I think I took I think I took my
own advice or the man I don't know the
social distancing
about the shutting down okay but not a
travel over a foot of activity so my
question is does you make this next
decision which you have said maybe the
most difficult or important decision of
your presidency will you assure the
American people that you will again take
the advice of the doctors of doctor
kouchi of dr. Burks will you take the
advice of the health experts before you
will and many other people also but I
will absolutely take their advice would
you go just would you come against their
recommendation if they say you need
another 15 or 30 I don't think it would
be likely because I think we're not very
far from being on the same page yes mr.
president one thing that Governor Cuomo
said today is that states do not have
the capacity to do mass cope in 19
testing ahead of a reopening yeah they
have to do look you're supposed to be
which is the diagnostic tests or
equipment and needs federal help so will
they may need help but they're there
they're on ground they've got local
mayors local representatives they have
people that do it and what we did last
time is unprecedented
we literally rebuilt testsuite we
rebuilt a whole industry because we
inherited nothing what we inherited from
the previous administration was totally
broken which somebody should eventually
say not only were the cupboards bare as
I say but we inherited broken testing
now we have great testing I just left
the top executives at Abbott who would
have thought that would have happened
where they have such a great test as
that and in fact what I'll do I think
unless you have any further questions
for the secretary of the Treasury do you
have anybody for see if anybody is that
the secretary and exhibits for me we can
wait we have to get him back to work go
there for secretary mination questions
one of my colleagues is not able to be
in the room they're curious about the
SBA rule that prevents small casinos
from getting some of this relief
is that something that you're taking a
look at if they're going to be exchanged
she's not small casinos but there are
such things as small taverns and
restaurants that have literally you know
small gaming things and and we are
coming out with some additional guidance
on that but I want to be clear it's not
small casinos there was a letter that
some House Republicans sent this weekend
about liquidity for mortgage servicers
yes sorry can you explain what you're
looking at on that front
sure so I think I commented on this a
week or so ago we had a subcommittee
task force at F sock that specifically
studied this issue we have all the
appropriate people on it Ginnie Mae has
automatically taken some action we've
had conversations with the FHFA as to
what they're gonna do for Fannie and
Freddie and we've said that to the
extent they need certain authorities
from the Treasury we will accommodate
that so we're we're very aware of the
issue quite frankly we've been studying
this issue way before covet and had
concerns about some of these non-bank
servicers not being well capitalized but
we're going to make sure that the market
functions properly thank you sir we have
seen in a number of these relief bills
that Democrats and Republicans have been
able to push forward different non-road
buyer specific funding priorities are
you trying to keep funding specific to
coronavirus and then if there are going
to be other additions for instance a
change to labor rules is something that
many on the Left when it some on the
right are wondering if they should also
if you should also be pushing for you
know their preferred add-ons
I think our expectation has always been
this is kovat related some people have a
rather broad view of what kovat related
is because it has impacted almost every
single business I mean I think we've the
president has talked about the Kennedy
Center which is a good institution
obviously that was not the major
priority the bill but they were hit with
kovat related so but know the president
has instructed we want to be very
specific in the next bill its kovat
related items
the Kennedy Center just so you
understand and that was done the
Democrats wanted it in we didn't want
that but they wanted it in and we had to
agree in order to get something done for
the workers but we want this to be for
the workers and for companies that
employ the workers that's what we're
looking for we're not looking for
extraneous nonsense what did they you
argue that at the time of it the
[ __ ] was being discussed with it
that was too disruptive to the global
economy is that I had nothing to do with
the China ban I wasn't on the task force
at the time I'm not even sure I was I
think I was traveling at the time but I
never had any I was not part I I did
become very active and after the China
ban but that report in The New York
Times was not accurate
I was not part of the task force at that
time and I was and I was not involved
matter of fact I think I may have been
traveling by Senator Holly to get direct
payments to employers to pay people
who've been laid off and do people on
payroll
that is the PPP the PPP is basically
sending money to small business fifty
percent of American workers to keep
those people paid and it's the most
efficient way every dollar as I said we
do through that it's one less dollar of
unemployment and more importantly we
want those people to have be associated
with the business so as soon as the
president is ready to open up the
economy those businesses are together we
don't want those businesses to fall
apart that's why this is such a
successful program but about the
unemployment indirectly to the States we
would have preferred that it was sent
directly to the people the Democrats
wanted it to be sent through the
unemployment system and you know I've
talked to you about it we have 40 year
old equipment in many of those systems
that run by the state but I'm hearing
they're getting the money out anyway so
some some of them are and some of the
states aren't and we encourage you know
we're working with the states to try to
update their computers but it's a long
haul
phase four Steve phase four come on
Steve you just said you said with
someone is President of the United
States their authority is total that is
not true who okay you know we're going
to write up papers on this it's not
going to be necessary because the
governors need us one way or the other
because ultimately it comes with a
federal government that being said we're
getting along very well with the
governors and I feel very certain that
there won't be a problem yeah please go
ahead has any governor agreed that you
have the authority to decide when their
state I haven't asked anybody because no
you know why because I don't have to go
ahead enough please you mentioned the
vice president's call with the
governor's today governor Hogan of
Maryland has urged your administration
to ask Congress for 500 billion to help
stabilize budgetary shortfalls created
by course if Governor Hogan very much we
appreciate governor Hogan's statement
como said that care is act ignored state
government warming shortfalls do you
that request mr. spoiler [ __ ] he said
the cares act ignored the budgetary
shortfalls well they're looking at
things in phase four where they have you
know where they talk about states and
they're also talking about hospitals
they're talking about states who have
been battered and they're also talking
about hospitals that were certainly
willing to look at that Congress will
see what we all come back with but they
are talking about states and they're
talking about hospitals oh and
governor of Michigan Gretchen Whitmer
has on thursday signed an executive
order banning the sale of non-essential
goods if other states
non-essential goods she had banned the
sale of non essential goods many are
calling this draconian unconstitutional
as president do you think that if other
states were to follow her example in the
coming weeks intervene well I don't
think that's gonna happen I think it's
very extreme but she's doing it and I
think it's gonna be over a long way
before we have to start thinking about
it too much it is strong it's a very
strong position to take but they're
making a lot of progress in Michigan so
let's see how it all works the funding
for the World Health Organization we're
going to be talking about that very soon
of getting a full report I'm not happy
with the World Health Organization not
happy with the World Trade Organization
either we've been ripped off by
everybody and we have this country for
so many years has been ripped off by
everybody whether it's a world health or
world trade and they're like I call them
the Bobbsey Twins
they look at our country for years and
years we had people that did nothing
about it we're doing a lot about it so
we'll have a report and we'll also we're
also talking about the World Trade
Organization but we've made a lot of
progress there we're now winning cases
for the first time because they know
I'll leave if we don't get treated
fairly this country our country was at a
point where we've rarely if ever won the
lawsuits within the World Trade
Organization but now we're winning a lot
of them because they know I'm not I'm
not playing games we will pull out if we
have to we just won a seven billion
dollar lawsuit which was very nice
respective decision this week on cutting
funding for the
yeah I would say by the end of the week
I'm gonna make a decision on that you
there's a lot of right now there's a lot
of things happening China why are there
no consequences for China for the
misinformation no there's no
consequences we'll find out why would I
tell you concern that they still know
you started off by saying why are there
no consequences there are no
consequences you're gonna find out why
would you tell you you'd probably be the
last person on earth that tell go ahead
mr. vice president do you agree with the
president's statement and his
understanding of federalism that his
power is total under way they describe
there's anything you'd like to add or
any context you'd like to add to what he
weighed he was discussing that III
support the president's leadership under
the national emergency declaration that
he signed we're standing before you
today at the first time in American
history when all 50 states have issued
emergency declarations and the
territories this is an unprecedented
time in the life of the nation and
fortunately as presidents reflected and
our health experts will continue to
reflect because the American people have
heeded the president's coronavirus
guidelines for America because state
governors I have taken those and
implemented them even in states where
there was not a significant outbreak and
implemented additional measures as we
provided them with data about cases and
best practices we're making real
progress as a country without our
circumscribed and it's wholly well-well
make no mistake about it in the long
history of this country the authority of
the President of the United States
during national emergencies is
unquestionably plenary and you can look
back through times of war and other
national emergencies and as the
president said will happily brief that
but in the days ahead what the president
has charged us to do
is to work with our health experts we're
going to bring together an extraordinary
group of American business leaders to
counsel the President and then working
with the CDC we're going to produce new
guidelines based upon the data for every
state and territory in this nation we're
going to give them guidance and as as
the presidents indicated we'll will
continue to respect the leadership and
partnership that we forge with every
governor in America but this is an
unprecedented time but I I have to tell
you when you look at the fact despite
the heartbreaking loss of more than
22,000 Americans when you look at the
fact of what what the health experts
told us this could be I think I only can
feel a sense of gratitude to the
American people gratitude to the
extraordinary team that has counseled
this president the steps of President
Trump has taken that the the policies
that governors have implemented all
across America I mean we were discussing
today at the taskforce that when you
look at the European Union as a whole
they have nearly three times the
mortality rate that the United States of
America has today and that is a tribute
to our extraordinary health care workers
their dedication their tireless work but
it's also a tribute to the fact that the
American people put into practice the
mitigation efforts that the president
counseled the nation to do on the advice
of our best scientists now more than a
month ago and our hospitals were not
overwhelmed and are not overwhelmed at
this hour and I have to tell you
standing here today I I couldn't be more
proud to stand alongside this president
and to be a part of this team that has
served the American people during this
challenging hour and I I've just say to
you to every American looking on as we
see the numbers leveling and maybe even
beginning to go down I just encourage
you to keep doing what you're
because of the sacrifices that Americans
and American families have made through
these mitigation efforts you're saving
lives and you're seeing our nation
through this disease tell you you've
been talking to the governor's quite a
bit did those coalition's of states on
the west coast and to the Northeast did
they tell you what they are going to be
announcing before they announced it as
governor phil murphy and the governor
Connecticut expressed today that they
were going to be speaking on a and
discussing on a regional basis what
their recommendations would be and and
we assured them today we show them today
on our conference call with I think 48
governor's that were with us today for
the better part of of an hour and a half
we told them that what the president
would be producing as directed to be
produced or additional guidelines for
the state's certified by the CDC that
would inform those governors and local
communities and mayor's about the best
way forward based on the unique
circumstances that those states and
those communities are facing I think
what's clear is the American people have
seen the experience in Washington state
where this really all began for us and
in California and now the extraordinary
challenges in the Greater New York City
area including New Jersey and
Connecticut the challenges in New
Orleans and Louisiana and Detroit still
Chicago parts of Houston but they're
also seeing that in each one of those
cases that the mitigation efforts are
truly working and so we'll we'll work
with those we'll work with those states
and in some cases it'll make perfect
sense for them to work together regional
bases the president the president will
be I'm sorry I didn't hear you a
question can you tell us did they let
you know
once I didn't dairy I didn't hear was
like and we would like to have their
cooperation and we are going to have
their cooperation they won't cooperate
perfectly watch I let me just affirm who
the president said we heard it again
today in what I think was our ninth
conference call with governor's is I
think every American would be proud to
see the partnership that this president
has forged with governors across the
country I mean it is an extraordinary
statement and you'll see some data when
Admiral pull object gets up in just a
few moments but the flow of resources
from around the world that we've moved
into areas that have faced challenges I
mean this president has directed us to
ensure that every state has what they
need when they need it and the spirit
that I heard again from Republicans and
Democrat governors today was reflective
of that partnership and as we move
forward to the president's goal of
reopening America we expect the same
kind of partnership in the interest of
the nation hear me through the mask
early can you hear you will the District
of Columbia argues that they were
shortchanged in the most recent funding
bill because they were treated as a
territory instead of as a state will
that be made right in phase four well
we're looking at that certainly I heard
that complaint but the mayor seems to be
very happy with everything was she's
actually and she was on today saying
very good things okay yeah go ahead and
do that yes mr. president
you talked about this being the most
difficult decision that you are going to
have to take about whether to reopen the
economy I wonder how much it weighs on
your mind the thought that if there is a
second way you've reopened the economy
and you might have to shut things down
again it does and I hope that won't
happen
I certainly hope that won't happen but
it does weigh on my mind okay in the
back go ahead
think oh thank you a question for one of
my colleagues who wasn't able to be here
China deployed an aircraft carrier into
the South China Sea
except China see this weekend amid
claims by chinese state media that kovat
has reduced US military readiness
readiness in the region what kind of
responses are you thinking of will you
have a response to this action
China has their own difficulties we have
a relationship with China that we're not
happy with certain things that happened
over the last period of time as you know
and I've been very explicit on that but
we know all about that and know China's
we've seen what they did we've seen many
other things that they've done both pro
and con and we'll be just fine where
you've said they bring together the the
economic task force and then you thought
that the recommendations were happening
earlier than expected did you mean to
suggest that it could be before May 1st
you start recommending I don't want to
say that but we're gonna be putting our
guidelines and recommendations fairly
quickly in a few days it would be before
I'm never saying but look certain states
are doing very well certain big parts of
the country are doing very well they're
doing really very well so we're gonna be
putting out recommendations and
guidelines very soon Steve your
guidelines being
when they fit each area or they be a
uniform you see I don't want to tell you
now but right now we have a very strong
indication that we know pretty much we
have some good ideas I also do want to
get I want to have we'll have video
conference or at least a conference call
with a lot of very good people having to
do with certain fields whether its
energy or whether it's entertainment and
restaurants etc etcetera we have to get
people back into restaurants we have to
do what we have to do whether it's
deductibility or not we'll see but it
should be deductibility you'll get them
back so fast I mean they used to have
deductibility the restaurant business it
was one of the hot businesses and then
they ended it a long time ago many years
ago but we may need that to get people
back into the restaurants please yeah
Obama today Balian voting nationwide as
a possible solution to the states she
said it shouldn't be a partisan issue
and your advisers told you that that the
state lives
Honeywell absentee ballot are you
talking about I don't know math scale
because of the well I don't know what
she did I mean I didn't see that when
did that happen today there's a little
bit of confusion about your phone calls
yesterday with President Putin the
Kremlin is saying that you discussed
current issues of ensuring strategic
security that wasn't referred to in the
White House readout can you enlighten us
many things we did discuss China we
discussed many different things but we
was primarily a call and the oil as you
can imagine and they were very helpful
in getting a stabilization price
stabilization of the number of barrels I
think the numbers going to be closer to
20 maybe 15 but closer to 20 than it is
going to be to 10 and I think it was a
very important call I also spoke with
the king of Saudi Arabia and that was a
very important call and the bottom line
is OPEC plus it's called OPEC plus
because there are other states also
other nations we came to a very good
agreement place
so that what was the part about
strategic security was that I would say
mostly we were talking about China we
were talking about their borders and we
were talking about our borders a little
bit our borders with Mexico because as
you know Mexico was a big part of the
deal and Mexico really it was very
complex from the standpoint of Mexico
was not an easy deal for Mexico and the
president we appreciated a certain
amount of flexibility but we talked
about borders we talked about China talk
about Mexico
well I mean I we did talk about the arms
yes we did that was a very important
part of the call actually yeah good
point
you said testing is going great we know
that these machines have been sent to
some of the governors but some what they
were saying they don't have the
materials to actually ended up well they
have to get the material you know the
governors have to get the material now
if they can't get it they're gonna see
us I'm talking about the local
governments I'm talking about governor's
have to get the material now they have
machines in fact we're going to go and
digest mic to go into it as soon as I
leave they have very powerful machines
that they don't know they even have I'm
not talking about Abbott I'm talking
about the governor's they have machines
that are used for this you know what I'm
talk you know what I'm referring to it's
very big very powerful machines we're in
a certain state's case they're only
using 10% of their capacity and they
didn't know it that happens to be
Illinois John these 15-minute tests that
you sent out these new ones that you had
in the Rose card
they say including
New Hampshire that they donned the
cartridges actually conduct the test so
we will they get those cartridge what do
you think rapidly increasing them
rapidly increases well pretty quickly
you have other machines where they can
really work and a lot of the states have
the big machines that can do a lot they
didn't even know they had them they
didn't even know that they had them and
mike is gonna be talking about that
remember you mentioned several weeks ago
the that google was putting together
that website or that would handle the
drivers like and apple have you if you
give me humble an apple coke passing a
lot of people don't like it from the
standpoint of constitutional rights i
mean a lot of people don't like it and
some people think it's great know they
are working on that as i understand
testing website reputable and and it's
only operating and i think five counties
in california right now no booth is
looking at it but google is also working
with apple or looking at something we
have the greatest companies in the world
looking at things that in a year from
now everything that we're looking at now
is going to be obsolete that's how good
it is we have things happening that are
unbelievable i saw a presentation today
that i can't talk about yet but it's
incredible plus i think they're doing
tony i think they're doing very well in
the vaccines they're working hard on the
vaccines and i think you'll have an
answer for vaccines i believe that
there's some great things coming out
with respect to that now you need a
testing period but you're gonna have
some great things please
that Google and Apple are doing so
different subjects on the cotton oh this
is this is the Google and Apple I don't
know if it's a partnership or what but
they're working on some they're working
on more than one element they're working
on a couple of different things Google
and Apple Google is also working on
something as you know having to do with
testing I believe they're doing that
in a singular fashion so my question is
not about the drive through testing
website not that but on Google Apple's
contact tracing that they want to
they've got this process now where they
can put it you know contactors you have
your phone if you opt in you can be
alerted if you've been those your
contact with some of the car fighters do
you how do you feel about well it's an
amazing thing but a lot of people have
some very big constitutional problems
with it you know that it's an amazing
thing and it would be actually as you
know other countries are thinking about
using something similar but not as good
I hear Singapore is Singapore is
Singapore had a little bit of a setback
because they had a they had a break you
know that and but they'll take care of
it I know I know the folks in Singapore
they're doing a great job and they're
gonna put it back for it quickly but
Singapore and other countries are
looking at other things and some
countries are doing other things further
Americans you something I don't want to
get into that because we have a whole
constitutional thing we have more of a
constitutional problem than a mechanical
problem but we will be making a
determination on that that's something
we're going to be discussing with a lot
of people over the next four weeks that
would be a very accurate way of doing it
but a lot of people have a problem with
it yep listing question maybe it's
moving along I think I kids because I I
have to leave moving along quickly
moving along well it's a test that's
been going along for many many years
except now we have very modern very
incredible versions of it but that's
moving on the antibody test moving along
very well okay any more kovat 19 Kovach
19
status of captain Crozier the well
that's going through the Navy as I
understand it the Navy is going to be
making decisions on all of that and they
had a break in I don't think the ship
should have been stopping in Vietnam
when you have a pandemic to be honest
with you you know I don't think the
captain should have been writing letters
he's not Ernest Hemingway as I said
before and he should have been writing
letters and I don't think I don't know
who gave the orders to stop in Vietnam
but they stopped in Vietnam and all of a
sudden they get on and now you have over
500 sailors and and people on the ship
that are affected I don't know whose
idea that was but that wasn't such a
good idea in the middle of a pandemic on
this question of constitutionality I'm
just wondering what changed your view
because nothing changing no no I know
exactly what you can say nothing changed
it the fact that I want to rely on
States or maybe will or maybe have and
the fact that we've gotten that's one
thing the fact that I don't want to use
the power is another thing look look at
standpoint of the Constitution yes
because you you thought should be on
stone you can look at constitutionally
you could look at federalism you can
look at it any different way John the
fact that I don't want to exert my power
is much different we have the power you
as does the federal government have the
power the federal government has
absolute power it has the power as to
whether or not I'll use that power we'll
see I would rather stay John I would
rather work with the states because I
like going down to a local government
that's why with I guess it's now seven
states not eight that could South
Carolina did you know they went away
from what we discussed the last time so
that's why I looked at the individual
states they're doing a very good job
they're really doing a very good job I'd
rather have them make the decision now
the fact that I'd rather have that's
fine but I have the absolute right to do
if I want to I may not want to we have a
very good relationships now we'll see
what happens if you notice the few
states you're talking about they're all
with Democrat governors
but if governors are doing a good job
and they control it better because you
don't have somebody in Washington saying
set up a testing site
in Deedle parking lot of a Walmart and
we're in Washington and they're in a
state that's very far away that's really
it should be and it should have always
been and I've always said it was but the
relationship we have now with the states
and governors is very good and we'll be
announcing over the next very short
period of time exactly what we're going
to be doing okay couple of months
I'm fighters and Joe Biden he's the
presumptive Democratic nominee do you
have any plans yet on when you'll start
sharing or when the White House will
start sharing some of that information
about the front of I reserve well
nobody's cold about coronavirus about
from their standpoint look they had the
h1n1 which is swine flu and that was a
big failure that was a tremendous
failure they had a lot of failures and
you take a look at what you take a look
at the history and you know 17,000
people died and you talk about late they
were so late they were late like it
never even existed that was a that was a
big problem of course a lot of other
people a big problem too so you know if
Joe Biden would like a briefing I'd
certainly get him a briefing I don't
know what he'd do with it yeah please
all right vodka
I want serving on the out on the new
task force and how are you gonna pan out
what no then
different councils or tasks task forces
can you just explain exactly where you
have lights dance which is the White
House Task Force which really brought us
up to this point brilliantly I must say
dealt with governors and dealt with
governors all the way through and and I
was on many of those calls and every
call got better and better and better it
was hostile at the beginning by the time
we finished I mean today's call was a
very good call very friendly call I
think everyone's on line and again you
don't have anybody driving you crazy
saying they're not getting ventilators
and not getting all of the different
things that need more beds they have a
lot of beds right now and we always
heard I think it's important you know we
always are on the sake of giving more
even when we didn't think we didn't
think New York needed the beds that they
were asking for we didn't think they
needed the ventilators that they asked
for and we were right now in ventilators
we're ready to March I told you this
we're ready to March we have 10,000
ventilators we're ready to move them
anywhere in the country where we need
them if we need them we're also building
a lot of ventilators and that's going to
be used at some point I believe you know
we're gonna have stockpiles including
state stockpiles if they want to work
out some kind of an arrangement with us
but we're also gonna help other
countries whether it's Italy or Spain or
other France is having a big problem
they all desperately need Germany too
they need ventilators so we're gonna
have a lot of ventilates we have a lot
you heard the numbers we have a lot
coming next week next week we have a
tremendous amount coming okay final
questions no then we have in addition to
that we have a number of committees
we'll have a transportation committee
we're going to have a manufacturing
committee you'll see it tomorrow we're
also having a religious leaders
committee we have a great group of
religious leaders we're having
committees with religious leaders you've
been seeing what's going on with the
churches and all of that and we're going
to have a faith leaders committee and so
we have we're going to have a few
committees I'll call them committees and
then ultimately we're going to make
decisions so we're going to make
decisions fairly quickly and I think
they're going to need to be the correct
decision I hope so Steve form the
economic task force
when you want them to have
recommendation soon soon and they
already know what I want and so when we
form when you say form I don't have to
give them instructions these are very
sophisticated people these are the best
people in their fields so I'd have to
say she let's we just met and we're
gonna meet in two weeks and here's what
what I said here's what I want we've
already told him and that the the best
names in the various businesses and
professions and religions I mean these
are the greatest names the people that I
think probably know the best so we've
called them and we're going to be
speaking to a very soon and we want them
to have if it's questions or statements
we want them to have that for us and we
will have either response or maybe I
mean ideally we're gonna be learning
from them and we'll be able to do that
and put them put everything we learn
from those calls into our new guidelines
so we're gonna have new guidelines
coming soon I think it's going to be
very good I think it's going to be very
smooth and I hope it's going to be very
safe thank you all very much
sadly Shara is a friend of mine for a
long time he's a great real estate
person passed away was a great real
estate person great great sort of a
legend in New York real estate he called
me a couple of weeks ago said he's
tested positive
Stanley's in his early to mid eighties I
guess and Stanley went to the hospital
and he never came out
they went into a coma he was unconscious
for a long period of time and he never
made it a great man he left very
charitable really a great philanthropist
a very very successful person in
Manhattan in the real estate business so
I got to know him a lot he was so
excited when his friend from New York
became the president of the United
States he was like like a young boy and
he was not a young boy but he was like a
young boy he was so excited he thought
it would do such a good job and he was
so happy and he he was very proud of
what we've done and this had been
raishin but he was tested positive and
unfortunately he didn't make it
it's a verse to me it's a verse a I
think thank you all very much thank you
Thank You mr. president as the president
mentioned the task force today spoke to
48 of the nation's governor's on that
call we reflected on the fact that all
all 50 states had emergency declarations
in place which was a first for American
history 5.2 billion dollars had been
distributed to the states under the
Stafford Act and it was a productive
call and reflective of president Trump's
ongoing in a direction for us to work
closely with the states to make sure the
states in the areas most impacted by the
coronavirus have what they need when
they need it we spoke about the issue of
testing and supplies and I'm going to
ask dr. deborah birx to come forward as
well as Admiral of check to reflect on
both of those topics for you dr. Burks
has been leading an effort from the task
force from early on on rapidly expanding
testing it was early on that the
president formed that public-private
partnership with commercial labs and as
we stand here today more than 2.5
million tests have been performed and
when we add in the estimates of labs
that we have to assume with reasonable
protections projections have not yet
reported into the CDC we think that
number could be closer to three million
tests that have been performed as has
been mentioned the new 15 minute test we
are we are working closely with Abbott
Laboratories that the president and our
team met with today here at the White
House to rapidly increase the
availability of cartridges Abbott is
producing roughly 50,000 cartridges a
day FEMA acquired an initial supply of
that and distribute
those to the States but we're working
with the states to not only distribute
what's being made but also work with
other suppliers to create additional
cartridges a point that I'll ask dr.
Burks to expand on in just a moment is
the fact that beyond the new 15-minute
test by abbott laboratories beyond what
we expect to be a new antibody test
which may well be approved by the fda in
just a matter of days and an antibody
test that would be produced at the rate
of twenty million tests a month the
reality is that those commercial
laboratories that the president brought
in here the better part of two months
ago and initiated that public and
private partnership with have been
producing hundreds of thousands of tests
every single week but as dr. Burks and
our team have apprehended we we believe
at this point in time that of the Roche
equipment that is out there that does
the high speed testing and we inform
governor's of this today we think that
that that some twenty percent of that
capacity is not being used and with
regard to the Abbott in two thousand
systems we told governor's today that we
think seventy-five percent of that
laboratory capacity that exists in the
United States today is not being
utilized by our governor so we sent a
very clear message to governor's today
to reach out to their hospitals reach
out to their labs to identify the
presence of the Roche amplicor 500 and
the Abbott n 2,000 to get those
activated we literally estimate that
although we're doing over a hundred and
ten thousand tests a day in the United
States that if if our if our governors
and state labs would simply activate the
machines that are already there we could
double the amount of testing in the
United States literally overnight and so
I know that governor's teams watch these
briefings and
we'll remind them very respectfully
again to identify those labs and we have
a we have a team that now is deploying
reaching out to labs to see if we can
activate all of those labs secondly on
the subject of supplies I've said it a
couple of times from this podium today
but let me say it one more time
president Trump's direction to us in
dealing with the states on personal
protective equipment and ventilators has
been to make sure the states have what
they need when they need it we recognize
that while while we all watch the
overall curve of the corona virus in
America understandably the national
numbers the reality is this outbreak has
taken place in in its own individual
curves first on the west coast then the
New York City area then Louisiana
Michigan and now we continue to contend
with it in Chicago and Houston and other
metropolitan areas it has given us the
opportunity to ensure that personal
protective equipment and ventilators are
made available on a critical basis and
and I have to tell you we're we're
incredibly proud of the effort and the
partnership with states that has us
standing here today that that no one who
has required a ventilator has been
denied a ventilator in the United States
of America at this point we have just
short of 7,000 ventilators in the
strategic national stockpile but as as
Admiral Polachek will detail we're
already beginning to receive newly
manufactured ventilators we'll get
another thousand in this week by the
middle of May will literally have
another 8,000 ventilators available for
deployment around the country I'm gonna
let him describe to you the specific a
detailing of those resources but but I
want to I want to share these numbers
most especially for our health care
workers around the country in the areas
most impacted by the corona virus so
that you know the resources are surging
into the hospital systems
at the point of the need and we will
continue to do just that so let me
recognize dr. Burks to reflect on the
data and also on maybe some comments on
testing and then Admiral pull off check
if you just step up and then you'll
describe supplies will hear from dr.
Fauci again and then take a few
questions great Thank You mr. vice
president
I don't know if we can get the first
slide on cumulative cases yes thank you
so much
I wanted to show you a different way of
looking at it today obviously we look at
case counts per hundred thousand
Americans in each of our states and
metro areas but I wanted you to see in
absolute numbers how much the new york
new jersey metro area dwarfs all other
metro areas and so you can't even see
Chicago Detroit or Boston all of those
metro areas are under 25,000 cases you
can see that the New York New Jersey
metro area is about almost 250,000 when
you bring those cases together almost a
lot more and that's why you hear us
talking a lot about the metro area of
New York and New Jersey and the counties
of Rockland and Westchester and
Suffolk's and not Nassau and Bergen New
Jersey and why we're so focused on
getting resources to that metro area I
can see the next slide then so if I take
New York and New Jersey metro area out
this is the other metro areas that we
have been tracking very closely I wanted
to show this to you so you could see how
those curves are already starting to
plateau so if you look at Detroit if you
look at Philadelphia if you look at
Louisiana Louisiana's in green Detroit
is in gray you can see across the board
across these metro areas across metro
areas with have a higher concentration
of individuals this is what the American
people in these large cities have done
where it is more difficult often to
socially distant and then we're just
really impressed by the work of the
mayors and
governors to make this happen I also
wanted you to see this because you can
clearly see Chicago and Boston and Sochi
cago is in the orange and Boston is in
the yellow they're crossing Detroit and
that's why we have been very much
focused on the needs of those areas and
there's one and Providence is also in
that category it's difficult for them to
see you to see them because they're much
further down on the sly but the highest
if you look at the axis on this slide
it's 25,000 the axis on the last slide
was 300,000 and so that's why I really
want people to understand each of these
epidemics minor these small epidemics in
each of the metro areas we're tracking
independently as well as any epidemic
sand outbreaks that are happening in
some of our other states so I just
wanted you to have that perspective of
how significant the New York New Jersey
issue is and why we've been tracking
that so closely but I also wanted to
assure all the other states that we're
tracking them also very closely I'm
really working with the governors and
mayors and across and that's why I
wanted to see that not only are the
curves flattening in some of those major
metropolitan areas but they're starting
to decrease and this is what we're very
excited about these are cases we also
know that mortality will lag and so
we're really tracking also the number of
individuals who have succumbed to the
Cova 19 I also wanted to really note
here that yes our mortality is less when
you combine European countries equal to
the size of the United States and I
think this is really two things one it's
the incredible work of the American
people that it's also the incredible
work of our health care providers and
the system of each of these hospitals
that have the resources and the ability
to respond to the needs of the Cova 19
patients and I think you can really see
this superb health care delivery that is
happening by the low mortality just to
mention really quickly about testing
because you've heard me before talk
about it and then it was
a little bit misquoted and-and-and
misaligned but there are multiple avid
machine so I'm going to be very clear
having spent years in the laboratory the
high throughput machines which are the
Roche 6800 and the 88 it's at 80 800 on
Roche and the Abbott m 2000 these are
the machines that run between 500 and a
thousand assays at a time the Abbott
company worked really hard three weeks
ago in getting a million tests out there
to be utilized and they can make a
million tests a week for all of our
laboratories that have these platforms
and so far to date somewhere around
250,000 tests have been utilized in
three weeks worth of work and that's why
we've really been appealing to though to
the laboratory directors to really bring
all those machines on last week dr.
Falchi and his incredible team of
researchers have agreed to really reach
out and find additional Roche and Abbott
high throughput machines that are in
research institutions and doing critical
research work to bring them online also
to supplement the other laboratories
work to create a mosaic and a complete
strategy that brings together the high
throughput platforms with the medium
throughput platforms with what are the
low throughput but rapid platforms which
is this ID now ID now is not going to be
the answer to the number of tests that
we need over the next few weeks those
run a test every 15 minutes and we can
get about 55,000 cartridges a day but I
just got done saying that these other
machines of which we have hundreds of
can run 500 to a thousand in a single
timeframe and so we need to bring all of
these assays together and a team has
been created to call every single
laboratory and every single research
institution across the United States to
define the complete capacity in every
single state because it shouldn't be our
expectation that every governor
understands exactly everything that's in
his state
but we have to understand everything in
every state in order to be able to meet
the man the needs of the American people
as we increase testing now I know you
all know that in three weeks we went
from 300 thousand tests total to 3
million tests total in three weeks we
know that we have to further increase
that that has been done really by HHS
and Admiral Jarrar and the team up there
and we're going to supplement that team
to really bring on all of the additional
resources and platforms that we have in
the United States of America just like
we did with ventilators to bring all of
the capacity to bear so that we can also
continue to increase testing also of
course as these epidemics or size
decrease you can also be able to use
more and more testing for surveillance
but I do want to call out the 19 states
that aren't ever represented in these
graphics and by and large the states
have been Kinyon to do containment and
outbreak investigation and I've been
able to talk to many of those states and
I would just remind all of us when I
talk to each one of these state health
officials where they are finding
outbreaks are in nursing homes and so we
really knew that need to continue to
protect and we continue to test in
nursing homes because we know that
that's a particularly vulnerable group
and it's a group where often now that
we're beginning to understand
asymptomatic transmission no one is
intending to pass the virus on to others
but we know inin seneschal workers
around the United States people are
unknowingly infected and in passing the
virus on and so those are the ones that
we're very interested in finding and you
might say well how do you find them
because they don't have symptoms and so
this is where we really have to increase
surveillance in a very deliberative and
understand way and so we're really
looking what our sentinel surveillance
sites we I think we can see where
there's outbreaks because once people
have symptoms you can see them but where
do you do sentinel surveillance so that
you find them before they have symptoms
this is what we have done for decades
and HIV and it's what's allowing us
right
out to really control the hiv/aids
epidemic in sub-saharan Africa because
we're finding people when they're
asymptomatic
and treating them when they're
asymptomatic so this is something we
know how to do and it's something we're
working very closely with CDC and others
on to make sure that we can bring that
full capacity to the American people so
these are just some insights and what
we're working on we're continuing
obviously to track every single County
and community and then finally I'm gonna
call it on one additional group there's
a group out there of our HIV AIDS
activists and community workers that
understand these tests that I've been
talking about these DNA these RNA based
tests because they often get viral loads
in HIV but they will know how to explain
this to the community about sampling and
what it means to run those assays they
are essentially biologists they
understand all of these assays they'll
also understand the antibody assays
because it's the antibody assays that
they counsel and utilize an HIV testing
across the United States and maybe it
will be our translator to the American
public and to their local mayors they
understand these tests they are
essentially understand all the biology
and all the immunology and I'm really
asking all of them to help us
communicate what these tests are so the
community is ready for them because
antibody tests measure something very
different than the viral load in the
front of your nose that we're using for
diagnosis and so really being able to
understand all of those tests when to
use them how to use them will be really
critical but the great thing is in the
United States of America we have these
community groups that understand these
tests very well and we'll be able to
discuss them at every level with their
community
I'm gonna call it ever plug checkup in a
minute but I have to call on dr. Tony
Fauci and let me let me let me just say
something really straight from my heart
if I can and I lost my dad 32 years ago
today April 13th is always tough day for
our family and this morning when my
brothers and sisters were sending around
pictures of dad like we always do I just
thought of the families of them more
than 22,000 Americans that we've lost
and I just want to tell you that you're
on our hearts and you're in the prayers
of millions of Americans as you as you
deal with this heartbreaking loss as
well as families that have family
members that are struggling with serious
illness but let me just encourage
everyone that in the midst of that loss
because the American people have been
putting these mitigation measures into
practice there are families that are
still together today and I just want to
encourage you here at roughly the
halfway point of 30 days to slow the
spread to take take that to heart in in
no way minimize the losses that we've
experienced as a nation and as families
but but to be encouraged to know when
you see those numbers on the the vast
majority of states that because of what
the American people are doing it's
working and dr. Fauci and dr. Burks and
the entire team continually asked us to
remind the American people and we do so
again today keep doing what you're doing
with the 30 days to slow the spread and
we will hasten the day that we heal our
land
dr. Fauci
I just want to make one comment that
related to a question that was asked and
then we'll have questions I don't want
to take too much time the the the idea
about how we would evaluate from a
purely public health standpoint about
what I call re-entry into some sort of
normality as health people I don't know
anything about nor do I have a claim to
know anything about economics there
gonna be people to know a lot more than
I do who are gonna give advice about all
of the committees that the president was
talking about but the one thing we do
know is as health people as physicians
and scientists and public health people
as I mentioned I think over the weekend
on one of the shows is that some people
may think it's gonna be like a light
switch on and off
you know either out and we're in it's
just not gonna be that way because we
have a very large country and there are
different impacts as you see New York is
very different from other parts of the
country from the Midwest from the
mountain region California and
Washington different than New Orleans
so as we discuss and consider the public
health aspects it likely would be
something that I refer to as sort of
like a rolling re-entry it's not going
to be one size fits all so I don't know
what it's gonna be yet because we still
have time to look at it dr. Burke sue
does an amazing job with showing you the
data and the charts that's gonna likely
influence some of the recommendations
that we will make but I can assure you
there will be recommendations that would
be based purely on on public health and
the president will get a lot of other
input from others but we'll give the
honest public health recommendation
Thank You Admiral pull up Chuck get an
update on supplies and then we'll take a
few questions
Thank You vice president can I have the
ventilator slide back up thank you so
you start with what's in the stockpile
this morning and then here's the
contracts that we'll be delivering over
the
next few weeks we had 8600 ventilators
to the pool we already have that's the
that's the math but you did you get
there that's that's included the DPA
action with with GM and we'll say that
we've also issued what would be called
rated orders with all of these vendors
to allow them further long privileges so
to speak with within their supply chain
so these there's written the contract
this is the hundred thousand plus family
as we were talking about and continue to
work with them to ensure that the
ventilators actually show up so there's
a continue to work there and as we did
that we realized that downstream supply
chains needed some additional defense
production act worked as well you go out
to the air bridge 80 flights scheduled
37 complete 43 on the horizon you could
see the numbers of of material that's
that's been brought in to supplement the
volume that's that's needed I'm gonna go
through a a series of slides of New York
first though
dr. Burks provides me what I will call
as a geographic reference to align the
supply chain so all of those cities
you'll see a little bit of theme here
I'll be talking about a lot of the load
of the cities and geographic areas
align the supply chain to those
geographic areas to try to get as much
they're well realize for the rest of the
nation used supplies as well and then we
were aligned the supply chain to site of
site of care public hospitals VA private
hospitals nursing homes first responders
acute care and on down the line so the
last business week so Monday of last
week through Friday Saturday of this of
the past week these are the mass of
materials that came into the New York
New Jersey metro area and you can see
the the volumes there so if you go to
Detroit
we talked about there they're out there
hot spot
here's the volumes of deliveries going
into Detroit for that same time period
you can go to Chicago I'm gonna run
through this kind of quick but you could
see that the geographical I made that
the places that dr. Burks has talked
about is where we're concentrating
supplies you can go to New Orleans to
give you an understanding Washington DC
right so so now and talk about that
today was you know a very kind of early
entry into the hey Washington d.c
Baltimore right positioning supplies
ahead of need we hope in in Washington
Baltimore and you can see trying to the
volumes they're trying to get ahead of
that and Philadelphia's next and then
now the next slide is a nine city roll
up and so to save a little time I did
not include Boston and used it in there
so you could see the volume of material
flowing through a commercial network air
bridge their supplies into geographic
regions and then and then further
prioritize to to site of care now final
topic n95 masks so the Department of
Defense announced a DPA action this
weekend
that came over from from DoD on Friday
into the White House approved on on
Saturday and contract awarded today 131
million five companies 3m Honeywell
owners and minor ball decks in dräger
you know the cares Act was signed before
the before March was endured towards the
end there essentially two weeks from
that that money being putting the title
three Authority for DoD this action
takes us from a baseline of what
what was being produced domestically of
about 30 million masks upwards to as we
go through the fall into the end of the
winter 120 million masks domestically so
currently we're filling some of that
that demand from overseas sources right
and so the additive masks here through
this will ramp up lower dependence on on
overseas sources and that that will
essentially secure a big piece of supply
chain five companies six six cities
smithfield rhode island phoenix arizona
Del Rio Texas Lexington North Carolina
Sheboygan Falls Wisconsin and Aberdeen
North Dakota all either producing more
fabric or increasing production
facilities to have that ramped up Thank
You Admiral and and can we put that
slide I guess it's still up this is for
just the week ending April 11
we have distributed or directed the
distribution of 5.3 million n95 mass
5.5 million surgical mass a hundred and
ten million gloves we share that mostly
just to make sure our health care
workers know that the resources are
flowing we're going to continue to flow
them but this is just the numbers for
this week and don't include for instance
what the president announced I was able
to tell Governor Tom wolf of
Pennsylvania today the next week and
they'll be receiving two million n95
mass to support some of the healthcare
challenges that they're facing in the
broader Philadelphia area so with that
we will be happy to take a couple of
questions
put the admiral and then one for dr.
derionne the admiral wondered if you've
been useful as you're going through you
know all of those supplies that are now
making their way into the system you
talked about having to buy foreign
products you know as we're catching up
and making it wouldn't have been useful
if it had taken until mid-march from the
government to start placing bulk orders
for these kinds of supplies so I came up
from the Pentagon 20 of the March so
I'll speak from the 20th March on now
we're using the defense production act I
think you'll see much more use of that
as we go forward you know we make I'm
not I'm not equipped to talk about other
than from about the 20 of the march
forward you know you said that you'd be
you know giving the president your
recommendations you and dr. Burks coming
up with a plan that you guys are
comfortable with are you willing once
the president has made his decision are
you willing to come here and tell us
tell the American public what you
actually have recommended to him and
whether he followed through with what
you recommended I'm not really what do
you mean
like so when the president stands up
here whether it's you know May 1st
whatever day it is and outline is his
plan are you willing to stand up here
after him
and tell us all tell the American public
what it was that you had recommended he
do if there is a difference you know I
have to think about that because you
know when you have conversations with
the president sometimes they really
should be confidential in what you give
him because he's gonna have to make his
own choice I have to think about that
know whether he was actually listening
to help advice right yeah he is I mean
he I can tell you one thing he'll listen
but I think what's gonna happen you know
I don't know for sure is that he will
get input from a number of individuals
representing a number of aspects of
society one of them will be a health the
only thing that I can tell you is that I
will give him the advice based on
evidence my observation of what the best
public health approach would be just to
go back to where we started today which
was with the president's seeming
frustrations with some of the reporting
about his early decision-making process
February as I'm sure you know the reason
the press do that kind of reporting is
the next president becomes along has to
do with a pandemic learn some of those
lessons what having watched this unfold
closely what do you think were the
mistakes that were made early on that a
future president could learn from what
would the benefit of hindsight course
you know I I understand I don't want to
use the word mistakes because when
you're in the in the the fog of war when
you're doing something you have to make
decisions you get input from a number of
individuals it's always a moving target
and I just don't want to be have
anything taken out of context because I
already had one of those already in the
last couple of days so I don't want to
go through it again
I wouldn't say mistake good things have
done better of course I mean nothing is
perfect and you could always do better
but I mean I hesitate to say something
is a mistake bit of hindsight well I
mean I can't I can't comment about
anything outside of my own field but the
thing that that when I think back on was
evolving in my mind was something that
was a virus that was much worse than
what I had thought it was gonna be based
on what we had learned early on when
when it was first felt to be something
that just jumped from an animal to human
and really didn't have much capability
of going human to human and then all of
a sudden you find out that not only was
it not just animal to human but there
were a lot of it that's probably the way
it started but then as you go back and
you realize they were probably a lot of
infections that maybe if we had dealt
into that a little bit more we could
have learned that not only is infecting
human to human
but it's transmitting really efficiently
when I questioned myself I'm not
maybe I wouldn't say made mistakes but
maybe I should have really tried to
delve into that a little bit more about
what was going on but the information
wasn't as forthcoming as I would have
liked and then all of a sudden when you
find out that you're dealing with
something that is not only what had been
your worst nightmare because people ask
me that what is your worst nightmare a
brand new virus that's respiratory
transmitted that has a high degree of
transmissibility that has a higher
degree of morbidity and mortality you
know is that a mistake maybe I should
have been able to realize that Malia I'm
not sure as a mistake it was just an
evolving thing that we finally realized
and said whoa this is really worse than
we could have imagined what did they say
they could do well we spoke with Abbott
Laboratories today about how we can
increase significantly the production of
cartridges for the 15-minute test
because remember we're we are we're not
only scaling to rapidly expand testing
across the country today and it's one of
the reasons well you heard me and dr.
Burks say that we are we have an entire
team now that's going to be working with
governors and with laboratories around
the country to identify the machines
that already exist today and that could
be activated and doing tests but we also
we also want to work with Abbott
Laboratories for the longer term because
if the current trend lines hold and I
hope and I literally pray that we will
soon find ourselves on the down slope of
the corona virus in this country this
epidemic in its current form will come
to an end but as we make decisions and
in the days ahead to reopen America what
President Trump also wants to do is have
a policy in place to stay open and
having the kind of surveillance testing
of a
all around the country so that CDC can
do the immediate contact tracing when
you have a positive test so that we can
deploy resources like the new habit
15-minute test specifically to nursing
homes we spoke today to Governor Baker
in Massachusetts governor Hogan in
Maryland both of whom have been very
innovative implementing federal
guidelines for preventing the spread and
infectious disease at nursing homes and
we commend them for that but being able
to to to increase the manufacturer of
those devices so they can be deployed
going forward in the months ahead is
also a focal point of our efforts so
rapidly continuing to expand testing
today and the governor of Louisiana told
me today that they had tested at the
highest per capita according to his
numbers of any state in the Union we
congratulate him for that but making
sure that going forward we'll have the
infrastructure of testing all across
America to to deal with the corona virus
so should it return in the future with
that let me let me bid you all a good
evening and we will be back tomorrow and
I'm so coach it about these cartridges
and this timeline because the Nutri
governor says the federal government is
in charge of distributing those payment
is so what is the timeline a win don't
have enough of it because they say they
don't enough Illinois's that they didn't
have enough so look what's the timeline
that you're working with yeah let me let
me let dr. Burks address that but
there's a there was an initial tranche
that we purchased there's some 18,000
abbott laboratory machines around the
country and FEMA acquired a certain
amount that we're immediately
distributed across the states but now
habbit laboratories is literally
producing some 50,000 a day those are
available in the open market and we're
also going to be working with abbott and
with the states to deploy those
resources and we're also working with
other manufacturers to increase the
production of cartridges but if there's
more to that do you want to ask those
questions and I just want to make sure
that people understand so a third of
them went specifically to Indian Health
Service and these states that have
smaller epidemics 2/3 of it went into
the public market mostly targeted to the
places where there's high disease but
only 2/3 went that way so that people
could purchase them directly and
one-third went to the Indian Health
Service and to the smaller states that
really need these and so I think what
we're trying to do now is balance the
entire testing framework of medium low
and high throughput machines to give
everyone the maximum flexibility
state-by-state based on what the needs
are at that moment if there's an
outbreak and you have to do 5,000 tests
you're not gonna do them on an ID mat
now machine that takes 15 minutes for
every negative but you're gonna do it on
your high-throughput machine so making
sure everybody knows where everything is
and what is being run will be really
critical moving forward because we can't
leave anything not on everything has to
be on the table in order for us to be
able to dramatically increase testing
yet another
we went up by a log in three weeks so if
we're going to increase again it's gonna
have to be getting every piece of
equipment on let me just again say thank
you all for your your time and attention
and thanks to every American who's
joined us tonight and I just want to
encourage you we're going to continue to
lean into this effort to expand testing
across the country to deploy supplies to
our incredible health care workers that
have done such an amazing job in the
midst of the corona virus epidemic my
last word on behalf of the President on
behalf of our entire task force is it's
30 days to slow the spread and I know
we're almost at the halfway point and I
know it's been a month of these
mitigation strategies but I I hope as
you look on as you see the progress
that's made on the West Coast the
beginnings of real progress in the
Greater New York City area Louisiana
Detroit and elsewhere I hope it will
only steel your resolve to continue to
do your part to slow the spread because
we'll get through this but it'll take
all of us to continue to do it so thank
you to the American people for all your
efforts and I'll see you tomorrow